des scènes de chaos
comme c'est en ternant dans des fosses
communes la région de manaus dans le
nord du brésil subit de plein fouet la
crise sanitaire liée aux cours navires
us on se croirait dans un film d'horreur
déplore le maire de cette métropole
alors que l'on dénombre habituellement
20 à 30 décès par jour à manaus la cité
amazonienne doit aujourd'hui gérer plus
d'une centaine de morts quotidiennement
c'est le taux de mortalité le plus élevé
parmi les principales villes
brésiliennes
c'est une blague nous ne pouvons même
pas enterrer correctement nos proches
j'ai tellement indigné par tout ça ma
mère est morte du comice 19
la situation est terrible ici en ville
nous ne pouvons pas entrer
il ne pouvons pas dire au revoir à nos
proches les hôpitaux n'étaient pas
préparés se retrouvent saturé manaus ne
dispose que d'une cinquantaine de lits
en soins intensifs pour une population
s'élevant à 1 million 700 mille
habitants
personne n'est encore venu me donner une
réponse satisfaisante pour sortir ma
grand-mère de là afin que nous puissions
l'enterrer pour faire un enterrement
digne et elle n'est pas morte du coffee
de 19
ici des conteneurs réfrigérés stocks les
multiples cadavres pour faire face à
l'urgence sanitaire
un hôpital de campagne est en
construction et de nombreux médecins
venant de tout le pays sont appelés à la
rescousse